um
i've just realized something
good morning everybody welcome to the
baber and mid-suffolk
joint overview and scrutiny committee
meeting of the 23rd of november
my apologies for uh juggling multiple
screens here
welcome anyway i'm chairing the meeting
today my name is aleister mccraw
can i first remind you all of some
domestic arrangements i could please you
please ensure your microphones are
turned off when they're not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
and that if you're attending the meeting
to speak and you persistently interrupt
the meeting you may be asked to leave
could you please ensure that mobile
phones are on silent
or switched off i'd like to remind
everybody that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
and by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and the possible use of those images and
sound recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and the press
are not
lawfully excluded so now to
introductions i will ask the governance
officer
to carry out the introductions for us
sorry thank you chair um today we have
uh councillor heiress council brewster
and councillor mayberry and i don't know
if council humphreys has managed to join
us as well this morning
who will be acting as the witnesses for
the committee
and we also have emily eule assistant
director for
law and governance and also the
monitoring officer
and we also have jan robinson who is the
corporate manager for uh governance and
civic office who will be presenting the
report
thank you very much henriette can i move
to the agenda please now
uh item one apologies for absence and
substitutions
i'll now ask the governance officer to
have a role call for the members present
that's members of the committee
thank you chair um please reply when i
reply when i call your name
uh councillor dawson
okay councillor gold
yes good morning councillor grandin
good morning here councilman crawl
present council mclaren president
council osborne good morning present
good morning uh councillor carter
good morning councillor castin present
counselor epcon young president
councillor muller present cancer scarf
present and counselor
present thank you chair
thank you item two to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest
by members are there any to declare
okay if there are none we shall move on
to
items three which is jos 21
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the joint overview and
scrutiny committee held
on the 4th of september 2020.
now there is a confidential minute
attached
to this uh which would normally be heard
at the end
of the entire meeting requiring us to go
into a confidential session
but if there are no changes to be made
to those minutes or if there are any
changes but we don't talk about them
we can in fact take the vote in one go
so
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
but if it's the confidential minute
please don't state what the point is
just that the point exists
if there are no points regarding
accuracy then could i have a proposer
for those minutes
happy to propose happened
councillor muller seconded by councillor
osborne is that correct
correct right fine um in that case i'll
ask the government's officer to take a
roll call vote
thank you chair please reply for against
our abstain
councillor carter four
councillor castin for
uh councillor ebbkin young for
council gould for councillor grandin
four councillor mccraw
four council mclaren four
council muller four council osborne
paul councillor scarf paul
and councillor willem uh chair that is
unanimous
thank you very much the minutes of the
meeting on the 4th of september having
been
confirmed they will now be signed at the
next practicable opportunity and that
includes the confidential minute
we now come to item 4 jos 20
stroke 2 confirmation of the minutes of
the meeting of the joint overview and
scrutiny
committee held on the 21st of september
2020.
as before there was a confidential
minute so if there are any points
regarding the accuracy please don't
state what that point was if the
necessary we will deal with that
at the end of this meeting um are there
any points regarding the accuracy of the
minutes
yeah yes chair yes chair
okay does either of them concern the
confidential minute
no no okay could you state your uh
points please
yeah it's counselor muller here um chair
um paragraph 77.10
page 20. it's got an s after my name so
just a typo
thank you chad okay that's fine i think
that can be dealt with easily enough
and councillor osborne
did you have a point
perhaps i misheard there is a councillor
here
oh sorry my apologies cancer happening
so
on with regard to
page 20 and 21 of the minutes chair
uh section 77.14
and 77.15
uh it says band b-a-n-d
rather than ban i believe should be ban
rather than b-a-n-d
and then on page 21 section 77.19
it says quit i believe that mean
should be quiet okay yes
could possibly change to some extent a
quit
life does sound like something different
right typo again i suspect that's easily
dealt with so
the governance officer can confirm that
yes of course chair
thank you could i have a proposal for
those minutes please that's
again including the confidential minute
happy to propose
thank you councillor osborne in a second
happy to second
i didn't quite catch who that was uh
dave muller happened absolutely thank
you
uh now ask the governance officer to
take a roll call vote
certainly chair please can reply for
against and abstain
thank you councillor carter paul
councillor casten for
councillor ebbkin young four
councillor gould
council gold
okay i'll get back to cancer goal
councillor grandin
council grandin yes
um four sorry councillor mccrory
i keep breaking up four
uh council mclaren paul uh councillor
muller
for
are you there i am here sorry for
thank you very much that's unanimous
chair
thank you very much henriette um with
those minutes approved the minutes of
the meeting on that date
21st of september 2020 have been
confirmed and will be signed
at the next practicable opportunity
item five to receive notifications of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
none received thank you item six
questions by the public
not received and item seven questions by
councillors
non-received chair thank you
we now move to the substantive item on
today's agenda
item eight which is jos 20 stroke 3
review of outside bodies i would like to
invite
jan robinson the corporate manager for
governance and civic office
to introduce this report
thank you thank you chair um thank you
councillors so all councillors are
probably aware that as a council
we appoint councillors every year at the
annual council meetings to a range of
outside bodies
both of which are national and local
some of these organizations are
statutory and some
our organization which the council
contributes funding to and then there
are other organizations which have
clear links to our strategic corporate
joint strategic corporate plan
um these appointments
ensure that the council and residents
interests are represented
represented with key agencies
um what we did last year um was
with scrutiny was we we've done a
complete review
and we agreed at that point that we
would do an annual review well
as such things were delayed because of
the covid19
and a lot of organizations haven't
actually met but we have now carried out
that review
and um the the the results are listed in
an appendix
really um which is attached and that
details
all of the organizations we appoint to
their terms of reference
what the role of the counsellor is and
how often they meet
and there's some recommendations from
the organizations themselves that
um they don't look they they've um
told us that they're no longer meeting
or they've changed and and their um
organization has now moved into to
something else so
this report actually asks scrutiny to
have a look
at those organizations and um
see if there's any there that we can
recommend to council that we no longer
support if there's any additions that we
want to support
and really to look at how we receive
those
reports back from those organizations
because
i think we discussed it before but
didn't come to any sort of firm
conclusion
so i'd like um scrutiny to have a think
about
how we can regularly report on that
i don't think there's too much more i
can add to that um but i just wanted to
point out that if you are appointed to
an outside body
from the council you are indemnified
against
that and so if you're a trustee director
or whatever if things
were to go wrong you would you would
actually be covered by insurance by the
council
if you're appointed um in a private
capacity to organizations and i know a
lot of councillors do
um get themselves appointed to various
different boards
you are not insured by the council to do
that and i think that's
quite a key message to to councillors to
be really fully aware of their role when
they're
when the you know when you're being
appointed to to various
different bodies um to be representative
so that was the other
key part that i wanted to to highlight
to counselors
thank you chair thank you very much jan
the
information from the outside bodies you
refer to because we have a number of
tables here
we have a an overview of representation
of what seems to be mostly statutory
bodies
uh prepared by a research officer at the
councils
we have a list of appointments one for
baber and one for mid suffolk
is the table you're referring to
containing is the broad spreadsheet
which uh
runs on pages 39 through 45
with the recommendations of the outside
bodies yes chair that
that's the the one that i'm referring to
with the supplementary tree document
from the
technical research officer as well i
wonder when when we reached that point
uh jan if you could help us through um
with as we go through the list um a
summary of those
those organizations that feel our
representation is no longer required
just for the benefit of us all who who
may not have picked up on
all the points in all the boxes i think
it would be very helpful if you could do
that
would that be okay
i apologize for giving you extra work to
do
that's absolutely fine you're going to
test my memory but um
well i suspect henry henriette will be
able to assist because she's got a
better memory than that absolutely
if we could just just get some guidance
on the bodies that
that feel that way or have
recommendations to make to us
i think we'll probably need to work our
way through it the way i propose to
um approach this is by going through the
various bodies and the lists
in some of the orders and
the table i'd like to start with is um
if i can just find it here is the
outside bodies
overall overview of representation on
outside bodies
paper presented and prepared for us
which starts off with the assembly
of the east of england local government
association
and i'm going to briefly go through
these because that first body for
example
deals with uh the leaders of the two
councils
and in fact is uh the local government
association it's a representation
so it feeds in to um
that's a statutory requirement i would
imagine it's certainly a very useful one
so
i don't suppose there's any of the
members here present who have any direct
uh experience of operating on that
unless any of us have
been a leader of a council
now the next one is the association for
suffolk museums
uh does anybody have any experience um
on that
okay now the next one i do know we do
have two members who have direct
experience
um councillors casten and wellam both
appointed to the east suffolk internal
drainage board
and i wonder if i can ask either of them
those councillors or both
if they would prep like to provide a bit
of background
uh and experience that they've gained
both from the point of view
of the body they're on that they're
they're represented on
the uh effect on the council and their
own understanding because those three
things seem to me all to be
uh benefits um for the council
and for ourselves councillors caston and
welan would you be happy to do so
yeah absolutely yes um
shall i kick off first um or would you
like to counsel casting
i'm happy for you to kick off thank you
right um yeah so
uh yes we're both appointees to the east
suffolk
internal drainage board uh that board is
responsible for non-main river water
courses entering the north sea between
shortly and lower staffed and as you can
imagine a lot of the focus is
on the old the oar and the deben
um and particularly areas around minsmir
but uh there's also water management
schemes in uh debenham which
have we've been looking at uh and also
the um the gipping and its tributaries
we we see papers about routine
maintenance flood defense schemes
such as the one at snape and one at
lowestoft
and there's a big water management
scheme which um
basically is um pumping water just
before it gets to the sea
where it's still fresh water it's pumped
back up river it but into
farmers reservoirs that's a big scheme
that is
being undertaken at present um and it's
being funded
to a degree by the landowners who are
going to benefit but it
i mean it's a it's a win-win situation
um and because now the board is looking
at water management
more than just drainage there is a
proposal to change the name to the east
suffolk water management board
now my particular interest has been to
try to ensure that the the board
or the offices of the board are
consulted on planning applications
uh it was very very hit and miss there
were a number of
uh from my experience on planning
committee there were a number of fairly
big schemes which involved
um uh balancing pawns which
which the board knew nothing about um
because the board is not a statutory
consultant on planning
matters but they have got much more
into planning and checking on planning
applications and they now have a team
set up in order to do that and that's a
new team that was set up to
probably two or three years ago which
has been very good
um and really one of one of my things is
to try to get
the board to take over more of these
balancing ponds because they are
a concern in in the long run and
because the district council has some
responsibility for land drainage
if all if everything failed it could
come back to the
could come back to the district council
to sort it out and we don't really want
that to happen
um we have three meetings a year
um there's fairly infrequent
consultation
and and involvement between meetings
sometimes on a major planning
application for instance
um the board is responsible for setting
the budget
and also the tax rate to be levered
levied on land
owners so that's a quick overview
of what we do i think i think it's very
useful i found it very very useful i
think it is useful for the
for the the district particularly the
involvement over the um
of the planning applications
thank you councillor do you have
anything you'd like to add councillor
casten
no um thank you keith that's brilliant i
think um
i found that very informative as well
there's some
really good explanation of what's going
on thank you
okay uh would either of you uh cast as
well and cast in mind if any members
were to ask you any questions they may
have
happy to try yeah okay does does any
member have a question
they'd like to ask if they'd raise their
hand on the screen as councillor muller
just has
counsellor thank you chair uh i was
particularly interested to hear what uh
councillor william had to say about
balancing ponds
um i don't know whether you're aware of
counselor whether there's one
um offer cycle stroke footpath off of
gun cotton way
um it's still owned by chris nicholson
who are the principal
developer on cedars park but there is a
lot of invasive weed
in the in this particular balancing pond
which they had to pay to have removed
now since that they've put harris
fencing around this particular pond
which has
always been knocked over and it's an
absolute disgrace
i don't know whether the drainage board
would get involved with this but i've
written to chris nicholson several times
but they don't bother to respond to me
i know when i've discussed it with
colleagues in public realm
they decided they wouldn't take
responsibility because of the costs
involved
and sorting the problems out but would
this be something that the
drainage board could consider in the
future councillor well and please
uh thank you they could they could
consider it but the
request to be involved has to come
from the developer right because it's
gonna cost money
there's always a commuted sum that goes
with taking over balancing ponds
and i think there's either none at all
or there possibly one in mid-suffolk
that has been taken over right
thank you thank you counselor welcome
thank you thank you
councillor maybery i believe you have a
question
um thank you uh chairman um if i may
it's more of a comment
am i allowed to mention that basically
if it's relevant if it's relevant to the
group thank you um
we actually have a problem with invasive
weed in lavenam
believe it or not and this has been
maintained by volunteers from
the suffolk wildlife trust and i am
suggesting to
councillor muller and councillor wellam
that that may
be an avenue for you
thank you a point perhaps to bear in
mind uh at this point
unless anybody else has any other
questions yes counselor um
counselor carter uh yes just a query uh
regards the of this panel uh is it being
fed into
got by the local groups who do cleanups
like on the gipping
and is there any feed up in from the
environmental forum where
there's been reports of uh possible
um like um contaminants into the gipping
because part of it we've done an
investigation into um
flooding in lower stuff that was several
houses where i'm
damaged um so um it's
yeah it's it's it's really quite
a um a broad subject of the meeting but
it's
it's a it's really interesting to see
i'm following the
agricultural policies and things
quite closely the um and um a lot of it
also involves
the um the farmers using the water
as keith will know from the drainage
board um
recharging the aquifers and um
getting that water used on land or
you know in factories where it's needed
to it's um
yeah yeah it's it's a it's a really
interesting committee and
very useful yeah i think i mean it's a
remarkable piece of work being done
uh by matt hullis and his team at
suffolk county council
i'm always astonished by the degree of
expertise
uh and as i say it has sometimes had
direct use i would say for this council
i don't know if your experience as well
council casting in that
by being able to discuss water
management issues in terms of planning
applications
even in my own ward there have been
occasions where i've sought
clarification and i've known the
councillor
that matt sorry not counsel but matt
hullis will be able to find the answers
for me and give
a rational explanation uh right i have
two
yeah i'd just like to say i totally
agree with that i'm councillor mccraw i
think um
matt hullis is one of the most competent
people
that i've i've met it's amazing that
how what the the broad
area of his ex you know expertise about
he knows
like individually about every single
case is
fantastic and i discovered i discovered
to my great interest that water that
runs at the river
uh in my ward the store um
some of it has been transported uh from
the uh
the lincolnshire walls and that sort of
area which otherwise would have gone
into the wash
and it is in fact extracted from uh
having
not going into the wash and sent
uh all the way across the country into
the store further upstream
and then extracted further downstream
around here
and um put into uh reservoirs to the
south of us in essex indeed
uh right i have questions possibly from
councillor eppinyong and councillor
carter
councillor eppinyon
thank you chair um i just wanted to
clarify a small point that
councillor willam made which is that
uh he said that the east suffolk
internal drainage board
met three times a year in the
documentation it says four
so i guess we need to check which is
which and and
the other thing which um i'm concerned
about
is you mentioned that the there's
potentially a 30 percent
deficiency in the water needs within uh
east anglia and suffolk in in the coming
period
and i just wondered to what extent we
are planning
to mitigate that with especially given
the amount of
housing that we're under pressure to to
provide for our for people and
because clearly the more houses we built
the more demand there will be on the on
our water resources
absolutely right and in fact that
addresses the need for this discussion
because
on the assumptions that are built in to
the case
the requirement for water takes account
of the increased demand for housing um
the likelihood
of such housing but also uh increases in
agriculture
so it's a strategic approach with this
very much in mind
uh all i can tell you is that the uh
the planning for this is so extensive
there must be
something like 50 different partners in
a water management um partnership all
the way across the region
uh which includes everything you can
think of from
cambridge university through local
authorities
through environmental groups the
environmental agency
you name it they are probably involved
this is a huge project um and it will be
an ongoing project
uh the water shortage that is
anticipated
is is no joke it is absolutely real
councillor casten did you wish to
comment at all on that
yeah i just i just wanted to add that
that kind of goes into the um
the um suffolk flood risk scrutiny um
committee because in the last meeting we
were looking
at um heat maps and um mod
modelling of um where we think that
needs going to be
and by what increase all over the
whole of suffolk and it's amazing work
that they're doing they're
they're looking at exactly where there's
likely to be
you know your key service centers and um
key industrial areas
like for instance um i should think this
um
we we heard during the local plan um
debate
that um certain areas were um
we couldn't can have a um another
sort of meat processing plant um or
something like that because the water
wasn't available and that this is all
modelling that's done um from that the
suffolk flood
that suffolk county council um the
department there it's um
it's it's very it's it's very intricate
and it's the you know there's a huge
amount of
information available but yeah they are
doing exactly that looking into
um where that demand will be yeah
there's a major cultural shift going on
in terms of water management in the past
we were desperate to try and avoid
flooding and trying to get rid of water
um as fast as possible to stop it
flooding now we are trying to
use it better on the way um to spread it
out
to uh consider for example water meadows
where
the land itself retains the water we
have to look at hard surfaces there are
so many different areas
uh i think they'll probably feed into a
lot of concerns in the future so instead
of pumping water out to see where it
mixes with salt water
we need to retain that water within the
land
um so that fresh water is as valuable
resource
as we have does that help you council
epigong
uh thank you chairman yes it does uh
because
apart from uh um residential
accommodation of course
as uh councillor casten has mentioned
there is the issue of
industrial development and certainly in
and around the stone market we have
of course gateway 14 coming down this
down the pike here
and i guess that will also have some
demands and
i guess it's important that
sustainability both across
energy and water resources is taken into
consideration with these developments
on the water management side industrial
use in fact fours a
a sort of fairly small third third in
third place behind
uh domestic and agricultural use in east
anglia
but there's no way there's no always a
possibility that that could increase but
it's not
likely to increase very greatly council
carter
you've been very patient
yes unlike me isn't it but
uh i just um wanted to say i've got a
personal interest in this
would it would the group around allow an
observer to attend to a meeting or if
not with it
possible to share minutes i'm more than
happy to send you any documentation i
have council carter i have
immense numbers of reports that i think
you personally would find very
interesting
more than happy to share those um i will
make up a list of what's available
uh be prepared to do a lot of reading
i really appreciate that thank you but
it is absolutely fascinating
it will make a change to be able to read
about a a talking dog to me daughter so
i'll be
there councillor thank you chair
yeah um we meet in january june and
october
so uh what we have done this year and
and last year um so it's three times
it's three times a year
um and the other thing yeah you um
counselor epione is quite quite right
about having to
sort of hold water back i think probably
about 10 years ago
the drainage board would have tried to
get the water to the sea as quickly as
possible
now it's absolutely the obvious the
opposite so
um for instance in debenham um the
the water is being slowed down by um
a series of measures to to make sure it
doesn't get down
the the demon as quickly as possible um
and has a chance to
um uh find its way into the aquifer
thank you very much councillor well i
think we spent a fair amount of time on
water
um that those two bodies did seem to
belong together
what i'd like to do now is move on to
the next body on the
statutory list to the outside bodies uh
councillor osborne um not our councillor
osborne but the other councillor osborne
represents baber district council on the
gainsborough house society
um i think that's fairly obvious what
that's for it's to preserve the
gainsborough
house as a memorial i don't know if
councillor osborne um can make any
comment on this
or wishes to
no we'll pass the flat that that's a
body that uh has
seen uh quite a bit of attention over
the years
and indeed quite a lot of support from
baber district council
the greenways countryside project uh
is a jac what's the jack
anybody elucidate okay
we'll move on to that we don't have
either councillor hardac or councillor
norman here
the haven gateway partnership i notice
we have uh which has
got representation from councillor halt
council award from bdc and councillor
brewster
from mid-suffolk councillor brewster i
don't know if you could provide any
background on the haven gateway
partnership for the members
hello councillor brewster can you hear
me
at this point i'm beginning to wonder if
anybody can hear me
i can hear you oh that's fine
the haven gateway partnership and i have
to confess i have a personal interest
because
uh my ward is literally lies on
on the haven gateway at least i think it
does
it probably does yes yes um yeah
i was going to say obviously it it is a
a cross
border organization
which certainly in the past has proved
very very useful
um haven gateway partnership
has gone through quite a sticky time i
have to say
um and trying to sort of uh
reinvent themselves to to do more
having said that um
i have got some concerns recently
uh it has um
it has seemed more essex-centric
than uh suffolk although
obviously um east suffolk
and baba are part of it
um which is very important for east
suffolk because of the the port of felix
though which is also
has membership i think
certainly baber could have some benefit
out of it
i'm really quite unsure of the benefits
at the moment anyway the mid suffered
getting out of it
and i have um over the last
two months um asked our
um fiona to ml to
speak to the director there just to see
what they
are progressing for any any work in
in mid-southwest certainly
and and obviously baber as well to come
to that
um although obviously as you said you
you you
sit almost on the border of it um
well i have a specific reason councilor
brewster which i'll come to later in
questions but um
i mean do you do you obviously have some
doubts then about the
value of it as far as mint suffolk goes
um
and and i have some questions from the
baba point of view
okay um i'll try and answer the baby
once well i'm not sure you'll be able to
but i mean my experience
in haven gateway partnership has
literally been by hearing its name
um when a matter concerning uh a
particularly awkward
uh railroad crossing at manning tree
station
uh which of course is the last rail and
road crossing point between suffolk and
essex
uh it's a notorious bottleneck not to
say a potentially dangerous one
um it's been the subject of debate for
oh 30 or 40 years or so
and particularly with increases in road
and rail traffic um
and uh at a big summit of involving all
the mps of bodies department of
transport
the uh job was handed over to the haven
gateway partnership
to uh can carry out a viability
assessment for
uh having finding the funding to have a
study
on looking at the mandatory crossing um
which is basically like kicking it so
far into the long grass that it will
never be found again
um i've heard nothing since that was
three years ago possibly four
and i have to say i i question what the
bet counts benefit the council is
getting from the haven gateway
partnership
and if they regard us as being an
essential part of their operation
um i i think that is something that
deserves discussion
and so i suspect
yes that is one of my worries i think
they are looking for
councils to rejoin them east suffolk did
leave at one point
they've now gone back um so
i i suppose they are certainly getting
something out of it
the um the area you're talking about
certainly um i've heard them speak about
it
um but that was a while back
um and it does seem to have quietened uh
i think
but uh i noticed councilor bruce to the
appointments
are made um and involve cabinet members
um which seems appropriate because it's
obviously a strategic matter
dealt with at a cabinet level and i
wonder if that is something perhaps that
any cabinet member as cabinet member
could be taken back to the joint cabinet
to discuss but i personally would say
from your
evidence and from my own thoughts uh
unless anybody else has any thoughts or
experience or even has even heard of the
haven gateway partnership
that perhaps that might be the route to
examine that
case i i think it might well and this is
partly the reason i am
uh going through the ada at the moment
um because i think she
also has some con a few concerns perhaps
not as many as i do but uh
obviously it's costing us money um
and and i'm i'm not absolutely certain
in my mind
that that money is being spent as well
as it could be okay can we make a side
note then
uh if i can ask the governance officer
to make a side note that
the haven gateway partnership is
something that we might want
to include in a recommendation
obviously that will be for members to
decide but can we just make a side note
and come back to that later
henry yes yes yes thank you very much
thank you very much council brewster i
don't want to keep it on everything for
too long because there's a lot to get
through here
home home start mid suffolk this is
entirely a mid-suffolk group
um represented the representative there
being councillor hadingham is not
present
uh so we don't have a witness for that
uh ipswich and district citizens advice
bureau
now citizens advice bureaus uh both the
stone market
ipswich and uh um
sudbury operations have been the subject
of scrutiny
by this committee um in regard of value
and funding
in the in the previous years and in fact
we will be continuing that
in this council year so
uh we have a number of people who have
experience
on um citizens of vice bureau and it
appears there are some slight
differences
between the approach taken in the two
councils now councillor huron who's the
representative on the ipswich cab
isn't present but i do know we have
um some voluntary representatives here
who are not representing baba district
council
but representing um themselves and
operating as perhaps trustees i wonder
if anybody could uh
what would like to address citizens
advice bureaus in general
rather than in particular
councillor muller i see councillor
carter's hand is still up is that from
before councillor carter
uh no this was both for cab and home
start because
well let's go back to home start
councillor carter because i did rather
brush over that
um as actually i have not appointed to
it but i
have had personal benefits from it
i can i can say from feeding back from
the
um in following the minutes of the
meetings that have been scheduled uh if
there have been quite a it has
to me at least seem to be quite
beneficial to for the council to have a
feedback on this is actually homestart
mid
and west suffolk so if there were to be
any appointments
from labour council onto it i would
think it would be quite
beneficial especially if we are
a sort of joint council it would be
beneficial to have a representation from
both mid suffolk
and from baber possibly okay can we make
a note of that henriette
just as a possibility um anybody else
want to discuss home start before we
move back to cab thank you council
carter
right councillor muller then councillor
mayberry councillor muller
yeah thank you chair yeah i've actually
been a trustee on the
mid-suffolk uh cab since 2015.
um we meet on a fairly regular basis and
in fact we've got our agm
this year's adm tomorrow virtually it's
a very good group we obviously discussed
the
the funding which we get obviously from
mid-suffolk district council we get
funding from suffolk county council
and various other funders um throughout
the district
um they're a very very busy organization
in mid-suffolk especially natalie with
all the various issues rain covered and
problems with
people have with bills etc they've
continued to work throughout the period
doing a sterling job and it's actually
just nice to be a part of that to report
back
one excellent job all the volunteers and
the pay staff actually do
and i i don't know whether members are
aware but carol eagles who was the
uh chief officer at mid-suffolk she's no
move to take over at west suffolk
and simon clifton is now deputising in
that role for at least a year
as the chief officer of the mid-suffolk
cab
thank you chair thank you
sorry councilman thank you very much
councillor mayberry
uh thank you very much chairman um i
think i need
to to declare that i'm actually a
director of sudbury citizens advice
um and if you do not wish me to speak
then that's absolutely
fine it would be a non-pecuniary
interest presumably so i don't think
there's any conflict
thank you thank you very much um can i
just point out that they have actually
changed their name
they are now citizens advice the bro was
dropped a few years ago
it's just citizens advice i know it's so
easy
um to uh to refer back to it
the citizens advice in sudbury they run
a terrific program for
debt advice which is one of our biggest
items and that covers all manner of
items from
tenancy rent arrears to
any debt with any credit card
provider many many items are covered by
that
i think they all value they all work
extremely hard i think representation
on it is really useful
however and i know somebody
who's there will make a comment i really
do not think it's helpful
when there is a husband and wife team
together
on one board whether it's for
representing
labor or whether it's representing
themselves personally
okay i think that's a moot point
there will be a conflict of interest
even if two people say they are
completely separate
i say this with some experience my son
used to be
a district councillor and i refused to
sit on any subcommittee that he was on
because i didn't think it was correct
and that is the way we should go
well i think everybody makes their own
personal choices in these matters
um but i think we're really discussing
the matter of citizen's advice
and i will now call it ca um as a
principle and and and as a matter of
representation
councillor wellam um has a point here
council of welling yeah thank you chair
um
when we've started talking about
citizens advice we
we noted that um in mit suffolk
we have no observer at the mid-suffolk
citizen's advice um where as
in baba there are representatives as
observers
at two of the citizens advice
centers um so i i
i wondered why this was and i believe
historically
the the districts have appointed um
either appointed trustees or appointed
board members
who have taken an active role but that
stopped because there was a potential of
a
conflict of interest in that um
you you might have a district councillor
as a board member voting for or against
or or pushing for a grant from the
district council so i can understand why
why the the districts don't appoint um
trustees what what i
um i couldn't understand was why
mid-suffolk don't have an observer
and i felt it it would be advantageous
to have an observer and
i think from what i've heard so far it
would be advantageous for
mid suffolk to have an observer at mid
suffolk um
councillor muller i'm sure does a
sterling job there
but but he he is there in his own right
um so he has no remit to report back
to the the district in any way shape or
form
i raised this with the leader um and
the response from the leader was that
um she didn't wish there to be an
observer
at the mid-suffolk um citizen's advice
um and the reason she gave was that
mid-suffolk uh mid-suffer sorry
bmc um our officers
are meet regularly with officers of
mid-suffolk citizens advice um
but i felt and i still feel that that's
not quite the same
as having an observer an observer could
get a feel for the direction that
uh that the uh ca is going in
uh and what potentially needs there
might be and can report that back
to other members um or there could be a
a more formal report back
thank you councillor i mean i think it's
fairly clear there is a difference in
opinion between the two different
councils
and that's fair enough we are sovereign
councils each council and each cabinet
is entitled
to take its own viewpoint but uh
obviously we're also
all councillors i have to say from a
personal point of view i've always been
grateful for the fact that as well as
officer involvement we have member
involvement
um the fact that we contribute money um
to the cas i don't think he's either
here nor there were
anybody to feel there was a potential
conflict of interest they could uh
quite simply declare it uh as a
non-pecuniary interest
um but declined to vote but i don't see
they should be able to
be declined from being involved um
i don't think it does any harm councilor
carter did you wish to come back on
citizen's advice
uh yes i was going to make the sailing
point as a councilor whalum
i did have a quick question as well
should i declare as i have been a
uh beneficiary i have been a client of
the citizens advice
in the past and i don't think it's
necessary councillor carter as a
private matter and that that the whole
point of citizens advice is that it
provides confidential
and and dispassionate um rational
information for members of the public
who require that
information and what want to be able to
deal with somebody who has
no acts to grind whatsoever
and that can only be useful and we've
seen the value of ca
particularly through the pandemic and
we're likely to see it
after the pandemic and in the aftermath
in the years to come i think if anything
ca's
value has been re-demonstrated to the
possibly to the highest level
any of us thought imaginable uh
we have three ants sorry sorry it
certainly has i
did i wanted to have a query as well
garden um
with mid-southwest having an observation
but um
uh they are having an obviously over on
both
the west suffolk ceo a citizen device
and on the it switch i did once we have
we have
we have sudbury and ipswich yeah
because those are we contribute to both
mostly though to the sudbury one
i just wanted to know some feedback on
the benefit of being on
two different ones uh whether or not it
did we get any feedback on
uh clients that would go to it such
rather than sudbury
possibly would they go to mid suffolk
they tend to have different client bases
i would say uh the
west um of the baber district would go
to sudbury
whereas in my neck of the woods and the
shotley peninsula and
they would more likely go to ipswich at
least that was the case
before lockdown now of course the vast
majority of ca's work has been done by
phone and uh virtually certainly i just
wondered if
a benefit would be to advise mid suffolk
to have an observer
both on
okay that's a very good point i think
that particular recommendation would
have to be coming from
the mid suffolk members it would be
inappropriate for the baby members to be
making such a recommendation
to mid-suffolk but i think we can mark
that one down as something to return to
in recommendations
should which mid-suffolk members wish to
make a recommendation to their cabinet
to re-investigate the possibility of
such an observer
that would that be uh the west best way
of approaching it councillor carter
councillor wellam
i would think yes yes chair but could
could i ask one of the officers a
question and my
understanding is that it is the leader
who does
the appointing and is more or less
ratified or noted
by council so it isn't council
who decide um who to appoint and what to
appoint to
it is it is in the gift of the leader
but i just
could could do with having that
clarified if i may please
henriette are you able to yes i can
respond to that chair
that is uh absolutely correct it is the
leader who um
uh what should we say determine so
negotiate who will be representing
um on outside bodies and she uh
negotiate this with the group leaders as
far as i'm aware
jen can you so um just
just to clarify that so our all outside
bodies are
appointed by council um that is
definitely
most definitely a council function but
obviously when you have an
administration
it's the leader who indicates what
positions
she may wish to take up um and
therefore would make those
recommendations to council
and any that they don't wish to take up
would then obviously fall to
the parties not in the administration
um i think this is customer practice
with the cab
it's not it's something that they
decided a while ago
not to have an observer or
representative on there and it was
because of the conflict
because we do fund them quite a lot of
money and
um it was felt that councillors in their
own right
not through a council appointment could
sit on there as
a board member or or an observer if they
so wished
i have to say jan from my my own point
of view i'd have thought if you're
giving somebody some money you're
entitled to have a little say
in um in the direction that money is
spent in but
um if mid-suffolk member we would be
correct though if we wish to make a
recommendation or the mid-suffolk
members wish to make such a
recommendation
in making it to the cabinet
um i think your recommendation would go
to to council
to the council yeah in that case the
council would obviously vote on it and
okay you know yeah well if we can pencil
that in as a potential
recommendation we can come back to that
later okay uh are members happy with
that i have seen two hands still raised
i
don't know if they're from before well
it was i was just kept my hand up in
case i wanted to come back um but now
i'm i'm happy with that thank you very
much thanks for the clarification
thank you uh right the next item on this
list chairman
yes sorry counselor maybe i apologize no
thank you um i'd
take my hand down and put it back up
again um
i think an observer on citizen's advice
is a really good idea they do not have
any voting rights
at all but at least they can view what
is being
what is happening at the citizens advice
center
the and as i have already said one of
the biggest
issues is um debt advice
and there is a huge amount
percentage of debt advice which is given
to baber
tenants and i really do think
that the district council should
acknowledge this and be aware
that it is um it is vitally
important that they recognize how much
advice citizens advice are actually
giving
to baby tenants um for apart from rental
um arrears council tax arrears all
manner of arrears
thank you very much councillor mayberry
thank you thank you
i think we can pencil that one in the
ipswich strategic
planning area board um also appears to
be
um a cabinet function uh because it's a
strategic matter
i don't think we have anybody present
here who can um add anything to that
the next one that i do think is
something that matters to some of us
anyway
which uh probably mostly concerns baber
district council it is the
joint um advisory committee
uh and partnership with dead and vale
and the suffolk coast and heath's
aonbs um currently the representatives
are councillors none
and davis um but i have had prior
experience
on the uh aonb for
surprisingly enough dead unveil my my
ward actually has a foot
in both of these aonbs were possibly one
of the few
few few wards in the country that
actually has a foothold in
to not one but two separate aonbs and
and i can say
from uh my brief experience because as i
say i'm at the edge of the
dead and vale area um absolutely
fascinating stuff
directly involved in the point of view
from the council obviously it affects
our environment
it affects our standard of living uh how
we feel about our place
um and obviously there is a considerable
planning implication um
all the more so um as we face more
planning pressures
i did see a hand up briefly from
uh councillor gould was that on this
subject councillor gould
sorry mr chen no i don't think i've got
my hand up
is it still up though it must have been
a glitch i thought i saw for a moment my
apologies
but all i would say is that the um
representation on the aonb's is
something that i personally would regard
as vital um and as i say any of us who
live
near or adjacent or in an aonb would be
very appreciative of that
any questions on that subject
in that case we'll move on uh local
government association again this is a
leader function
um and i i don't think there's anything
we can comment upon that these are
statutory requirements the
um there's two things there's something
called sparse and something called
assembly
i assume that they're different aspects
of the same thing
the museum of east anglian life now this
is based i think in stone market
um i don't know if any stone market area
members wish to comment upon that
particular
outside body
nope fine we'll move straight on and
to pin mill bay management this is on
the shotley peninsula uh
pin mill on the orwell uh also with an
aonb
this is a multi-agency or a yeah
multi-um
group um number of stakeholders
involving the ipswich harbour board
uh various uh environmental bodies and
of course the people of
of uh charlemagne distant and pin mill
um
councillor harold isn't here um but i
know he's been on that for some time
uh councillor gould this is in your
award is there anything that you would
like to
add to the conversation
councillor gould your hand is up
okay uh council epione i believe you
might have wanted to have to say
something on the museum of east anglian
life my apologies for skipping over you
thank you chairman all i was going to
really say this is a
an important piece of green real estate
within the town of stone market
um and you know we've just talked about
areas of outstanding natural beauty and
from my
point of view this is a very important
area of outstanding natural beauty
within an urban setting
and i think you know we must not under
underestimate
the value that he plays in the
well-being of our town and therefore
deserve the support that he gets
yeah i can remember taking my children
there many years ago and uh
and i look forward to taking my
grandchildren there at some point in the
future
uh that's fantastic i i think we've
covered as much as we can on that
without having direct representation
uh the key theater sudbury is
represented uh from baber
uh councillor stephen plum uh monthly
board meetings that's quite a
substantial amount although i shouldn't
imagine they're meeting much at the
moment
um suffolk coastal forum we've already
mentioned sudbury and district citizens
advice councillor osborne i believe you
are appointed on that
uh that's the sudbury version of ca is
there anything we should add
to that chair i think uh councillor
ayers has her hand up
counselor as my apologies i missed it
oh thank you chair no it's back to the
key theater
thank you i represent it for the town
council
in fact we have been meeting nearly
weekly
visit because of the problems
and um they have been doing as much as
they can
doing lots of other activities people
can go online
so we're meeting far more than we would
normally i apologize for
for misrepresenting the situation thank
you
no problem okay uh
councillor osborne i just briefly
touched on uh
on the uh sudbury citizens of isil
though i don't suppose it's
any different from uh our discussions
already
is that correct
okay can't hear this chairman
yeah i'll have uh i'll just make a few
comments about
as i say observer on the outside bodies
um
the ca be in sudbury uh since the
uh meeting forum of of i think it was
2018 um they're
excellent you know they found it an
excellent uh uh
area and of uh and the funding was very
much appreciated from from the outcome
of that meeting
um the advice center i think is
very much thankful for all the funding
of baba and the sudbury town council
and and they do find their own
fundraising
um due to the excellent uh chief exec
over the years in charge and of course
the treasures involved
over the uh times i have um i've been
appointed as a member of
of as an observer for the council the
times have
changed um with other uh committees
uh the times have meant that i possibly
couldn't
attend as many meetings as that because
it clashed to say with the other
committees
that i i've been appointed to uh
therefore a lot of meetings i've been
able to attend but when i do there i
find that the
advice that they've given out and the
and the officers there are excellent
um the advice center has had changes to
staff
and volunteers in the running of the
center
and although they're they're taking uh
uh
due to them taking full retirement i
suspect uh
these have been um excellent volunteers
for the
for the issues that have had uh been in
the
professional capacities that they've had
um
also the um
they've kept the trustees level high by
bringing in some
excellent new trustees there's been a
huge demand for advice in all
these areas of concerns uh for our
residents and therefore
their budget their yearly budget is well
managed
to keep the center running with their
full-time employees and the centre
itself
excellent advice manager and staff and
give full
full full commitments and and to their
to their work
thank you thank you very much councillor
osborne
uh there are no questions for that from
anybody
councilors
sorry i forgot to lower my hand it's all
right we've all done it
uh suffolk coastal forum councillor
davis isn't present and again we're
coming back to aspects of water so i
shall
we think we've covered enough water
today the suffolk health and well-being
board
uh baber have a representation from
councillors davis and gould
when councillor gould is with us today
councillor gould can you add anything to
uh coverage of the suffolk health and
wellbeing board
no i think due to councillor davis um
regular attendance i haven't actually
attended
any of them and i don't get any papers
so there's nothing useful i can add
thank you mr chair
thank you very much i mean you're a
substitute i take it on that but i
do yes okay thanks great we'll move on
then um
[Music]
the suffolk health scrutiny committee uh
councillor mclaren
uh is a weber representative and
councillor airs i possibly as a
substitute
uh would either of you like to comment
on the suffolk health scrutiny committee
thank you chair yes i would actually um
i think this demonstrates really good
interagency working the suffolk health
scrutiny is managed
really directed from the county council
our chairman is jessica fleming
uh but every district in suffolk is on
that
committee uh we meet quarterly but we
usually have five
six hour meetings so we do go through a
very heavy agenda each time
we link with the counties of norfolk
and essex quite regularly
we've spawned quite a few subcommittees
and we're in touch with all the health
providers
that within suffolk within norfolk
and within essex it is a very busy
committee
i find it very stimulating obviously i
come out of a health background
i think it's brilliant and
i feel it's very useful the the only
comment it would make
looking at the principles
of reporting i have never
ever reported on that committee
to the rest of my colleagues and that
was one of the questions i was going to
raise later on in the meeting
well i think this is actually the
perfect point to do so
um because i've felt this myself in that
a lot of us attend these bodies
um and we gain a lot of information
and i hope we are serving the bodies um
by our own efforts but the direct
feedback
that we give to our own council uh
either baber or mid suffolk
doesn't seem to me to be very apparent
and i'm wondering if
a recommendation is a possibility so
there being some form of reporting
mechanism and i don't mean a lengthy one
but just to say these are the subjects
we've discussed and to be able to feed
them directly back
either to the council or to the cabinet
at least as a matter of just providing
an information trail
uh does that more or less is that along
the lines you're thinking counselor
mclaren
oh absolutely i mean i had a list of
things that i thought
to be considered for discussion but
really in the 15 months that i've been a
counsellor
uh most of that spent in inside
latterly um i have never ever seen
a report from any other member
about the committees they attended and i
think it's so important that we keep
everybody up to date
that's a huge area of great importance
and particularly at the moment where we
are seeing
not just the obvious kovid 19 health
effects but the
subsidiary effects of the knock-on um
throughout the rest of the health
service
can i just say that we are very strict
um as you know i'm on quite a few
scrutiny
committees and um scrutiny is one of my
skill pass skills and
i've got to say the health scrutiny
committee does
put the health service and health
service providers
through strict questioning and has
had and we've seen the benefit of that
we're also involved with the development
of the ipswich
buildings or the colchester you know the
colchester hospital buildings
i have just been selected to go on the
planning committee for the new west
suffolk hospital
and so we have a wide range of interest
thank you chad this of course is a
suffolk county council committee
um and it's a separate scrutiny
committee to the scrutiny committee
so it is a full committee of suffolk
county council so it's across
authority which is something which is
something that this committee itself
have experimented in the past so i
thoroughly agree with the idea
councilor maybe did you have a question
or a comment
um thank you mr chairman it's it's
really
a comment because um having previous
experience on both the house scrutiny
and the health and well-being
board
council mclaren is absolutely right um
they they are both very very important
and with the health scrutiny
yes they do put some of the
health providers through very strict
questioning um i have seen it myself i
think what is really important
about both of those boards is that it's
two-way communication
so we may be asking questions but then
they also come back to us with questions
and i think that is
really really important as to the
reporting i
quite agree there should be some type of
reporting
i was always informed um by the
communities
of the community officers that it would
be picked up
at the end of year or quarterly report
it was but there is nothing to stop a
proper report
um councillor mclaren said it was for
all the district um
councils that is absolutely true for
health scrutiny in particular
it does include ipswich town and i do
remember
having some very interesting
conversations with
those uh representatives from ipswich
town on the house scrutiny
board i think what we should remember
is that those two boards also
feed down to other subcommittees and
it's now
not there but there was also a child
health board
that i sat on which was very very
interesting the times of when i had my
children as to what
is happening these days with with
parents
and children is is so
different there's just a great big
divide in many respects
and it was the greatest sorrow to me
when the local house trusts
closed the um centers for children
i think that was a real shame because
they did actually bring
a lot of vital advice and help to a lot
of parents
now whether or not this is going to be
taken on by
more by homestart i do not know i'm not
privy to that information
but there does need to be something for
child health
at the moment councillor mabry i think
we're just dealing with the existing
bodies
without re visiting old ones or reviving
old ones and and but i
i take your point that this is something
that should be looked at somewhere can i
ask councillor mclaren a question i
presume that there's considerable
involvement
with the uh ccgs the clinical
commissioning groups
yeah our just as our overview and
scrutiny has a very heavy program
there is a regular i mean i'm receiving
updates from all the ccgs at the moment
regarding the um the covid 19.
action uh and we
um our teresa hardin who is
our supporting uh administrator
i mean we get i get regularly every week
information about what's happening
across suffolk be that
to do with development covert new ideas
and of course we do have trusts that
come
especially in norfolk with mental health
they regularly come under scrutiny from
our
our uh committee okay thank you very
much
thank you henriette can we make a note
then that a
potential recommendation um
that raised as a point by council
mclaren and reinforced by councillor
mayberry and myself
that some form of reporting structure
from the outside bodies back
to the council should be uh considered
um
to provide not only value but evidence
of that value
to the council and to the public um
these groups we operate on and i think
for the
last vast majority of the public they
have no knowledge apart unless they pay
attention to our annual meeting where
these appointments are made
and the next time anything is heard of
them is the next year that those
appointments are made
and it seems to me that there's a
there's an information deficit there and
i believe that should be addressed so
can we make a point that that's a
potential recommendation
certainly thank you very much now i note
that i have nearly reached the end of
this but there are a couple
and the next one is the suffolk police
and crime panel
and councillor wellam is the mid-suffolk
representative
on that councillor welum is there
anything you can tell us about the
suffolk police and crime panel
i will try thank you chair um yes we
meet four times a year we have
meetings panel meetings four times a
year we have workshops four times a year
um and we are also invited to observe
the accountability and performance panel
so at at the uh
accountancy and performance panel
meetings the pcc that's tim
challenges the chief constable and then
at our panel meetings we challenge the
pcc
so when you say challenge that sounds
rather rather likely get into a ring
against each other well not quite
no we challenge the decisions we
scrutinize thank you
although i think tim likes to use the
word challenge right
so we scrutinize we scrutinize the the
the the decisions of the pcc the pro
work program the budget uh
and and the council tax to be levied um
and we we have a sort of a veto if they
if the cat if the uh council tax to be
levied is not to our liking we have a
sort of a veto but we are only allowed
to veto it once each year so it could
come back with an almost identical
budget
which we would not be able to veto but
we've we've not got to that stage
it's usually it's usually been um
by discussion and and the budget has
been pretty much
as we would have expected it to be we
cover
a huge range of topics anything to do
with with policing and pcsos
and and in particular their call center
performance has been
high on the agenda the the time to
answer the telephone
uh and the the value of the response and
so on
the the deployment of of office is not
not the day-to-day deployment of offices
but the strategic
deployment of offices and in my case
it's to try to get
adequate resources into the rural areas
and into stone market town center
because there
there tends to be um uh you know
a lot of activity a lot of uh police
resources
um given to let's say bears in edmonds
ipswich lowestoft and so on
and we we could be um not getting off
their share
um we get a whole load of reports
information bulletins the um
accountability and performance panel
reports
um and and also there are public
meetings which we are
well not not just recently but other
public meetings we have been invited to
attend
one or two of those have gone online but
they tended to be
public meetings in in the towns around
suffolk um i've been
i've been particularly interested in um
police engagement in rural areas
um and the use of speed indicator
devices in parishes
uh because there could be a good system
around the villages of
providing information to the police
um also concerns about policing the
nighttime economy
um and uh additionally um
who's who's supervising who provides
the sort of program of work for the
pcsos who are funded by mid suffolk
um because what we want to try to make
sure is that they don't just
get drawn off somewhere completely
different and
we want them to be looking at our
district council's
priorities and as an aside
um i'm about to attend the the national
annual conference for pcc panels
thank you councillor large portions of
that i was completely unaware of
particularly the matter about the veto
um which is fascinating um any questions
members
for councillor wellam on the police and
crime panel
castle mclaren thank you chair
um how keith how does
how does this fit in with uh local
police forums uh i attend the
spaber local police forum we haven't met
obviously because of the pandemic but
how does that committee
feed down to these local
groups and the other thing is that is
not listed
on our list of outside bodies but i
think it's important for me as a local
counselor
to be at that meeting thank you
well i think in that instance i mean are
you referring to the meeting that you
attend already or are you referring to
the police and crime panel
well i just wondered whether it links
into the local
uh police i'm not sure that i'm not sure
that they're not doing different
functions one being on
local policing and one being on a
strategic approach um
perhaps you councillor wellam can have a
discussion with that outside
and then but i think i think the basic
answer would be
um let me see i think our representative
baber
is councillor beer so you have to
have a conversation perhaps with
councillor beer to see whether
to do link in any way yes thank you
chair
any other questions members
well thank you very much that that's
what as i said sorry
obviously the police and crime panel is
working at a strategic level
um but part of that is to ensure that
there
is proper community engagement in in
the various local areas and but that is
done through
um our um scrutinizing
the police and crime commissioner about
the way that that work is done through
the commit the community engagement
offices of
of which they're there well there used
to be one
in every snt i'm not sure that there
still is but there are a number
of what they call community engagement
offices around
the county so it's a scrutiny function
as well
as as as a panel well it is a
is a scrutiny function entirely yes okay
fine it's just
calling it a panel is obviously i mean a
panel can mean so many different things
and
who can say councillor muller i think
you have your hand up yes uh
thank you chair it's just uh in response
to to counselor wellam's point about the
community engagement officers i can
confirm that uh pc
stefan henriksen is still the police
engagement officer for mid-suffolk
thank you chair thank you very much okay
let's uh put that to aside for the
moment i don't see any possible
recommendation coming out of that
discussion but we now move to the
suffolk
violence and abuse partnership and
council mclaren
i think you're the baber representative
upon this um
it's described as an informal
partnership but i wonder if you could uh
throw any light on the subject yes thank
you chair
um it basically is a meeting of
all the agencies that deal with violence
and domestic abuse
it is very informal um
there is no record i i think of those
that
attend i put because i have an interest
in in domestic abuse and safeguarding
it's therefore been of interest to me
and
i can't say that i contribute very much
to the
discussion at a meeting because it's
usually a discussion of those agencies
that are directly involved many of them
know each other
in sort of their professional life but
i'm very happy to sit there and observe
and again with back to the reporting
it would be worth me reporting on that
meeting two members
of course it does occur to me now i
think about it that this
both of these last two subjects to some
extent
feed into the west of suffolk community
safety partnership
which we we receive a a report from
every year
to to examine a variety of aspects
involved in community safety and
obviously policing and violence against
men women and girls
has come up every year we've looked at
that
so join together yeah but chair you will
see i'm a member of that as well
i know we're coming on to that
yeah well i was going to say a very busy
councilman you're very busy councillor
mclaren
shall we do you want me to bring that up
later then
we'll come back to the wscsp in a minute
i think because
uh the next one i have is is um the
suffolk waste partnership
councillors fleming and rc um uh
councillor arthur i know has been
involved since the setting up of the
waste partnership
um neither are present but um i i have
to say on observation it has been
operating successfully across the county
for some time although there are
obviously are there still considerable
challenges in the future now
we would come to the west suffolk
community safety partnership something
that always confuses people that
how we over here in baber stretching all
the way to the outskirts of ipswich
can be considered the west of suffolk
but there it is
uh east of suffolk is ipswich and points
east
west of suffolk appears to be the rest
of us um
now i think we have a representation
there again from council mclaren
thank you chair now this is one of the
issues that i was going to bring up
um in in my experience since i was
nominated to it i've only been able to
attend one meeting because it conflicts
with one of my major committees within
baby district council
and i did speak to the leader
and i assumed that he'd made
uh some changes to that representation
by myself
because it's vital that we actually
attend that meeting
but when i looked at the list i saw that
it was still
as it was previously so i said i must
take that up with john ward again
it's a scheduling thing and i think it
does come down to these problems i mean
i mean i have to say council mclaren
with the number of
bodies outside and inside you're serving
on
i'm amazed you have time for anything
else thank you jenna
welcome i'm just genuinely stunned
okay fortunately we do have a pretty
clear idea of the role of the wscsp
because we carry out an annual statutory
review and that will be taking place
in the new year so i propose to move on
from there if members have no problems i
know
questions on that subject are there
okay so we looked through that
report and i'm very grateful to the
officer who prepared it because i
personally found it very useful to have
those paragraphs and they
explanation rather than a tabular form i
must admit
tables can be tricky now we come to the
table and quite a complicated table in
my view
but jan robinson did refer to it earlier
and i think this one is the one we
should probably focus upon
uh rather than the just the list
of the appointments to both councils
before we do that however i note
that maybe members who serve on outside
bodies that have not yet had a chance to
speak so i'd like to go around the group
in turn and ask any member
of serving on an outside body that has
not had a chance to speak
or heard that body spoken about if
they'd like to contribute now if you
could raise your hands i'd be very
grateful
yes councillor osborne this is jan
osborne
thank you mr chairman yeah apologies
i've had problems with my laptop so i've
only just been able to get in
um i sit on um the gainsborough house
outside body group and i think it's i
think it's really key
obviously babe have invested very
heavily into gainsborough house and
rightly so it's a fantastic project
um as well as putting sil money into the
project as well
so it's important that we remain on the
outside body so that we can sit there
and
not challenge them but monitor the the
progress of the project
and also be a watchful eye on on how it
moves forward
during the project during construction
and indeed
after construction so i think it's
important that we stay on there we
we meet we normally meet every three
months but we haven't
met i'm just going to chase mark up
actually there hasn't been a meeting for
quite a few months in fact before
lockdown so i'm just doing an email now
you've reminded me to ask him
for um an update on where we are
etcetera um we've got no reporting
mechanism for me to report
back to other members at baber so
perhaps that's something that we could
look into at some point
to see how that can be achieved uh away
from a full council meeting because
otherwise you'd have too many reports
back and it would take too long i think
it's something we may well include in
our recommendations councillor osborne
um and i think it's important
you know with a variety of different
purposes behind the outside bodies
some are environmental some are
more matters of strategic business some
must be considered to be cultural
and they're all important functions of
the council
or a group to raise oh yes uh jessica
garden i do serve
prior to being a counselor i've been
serving on the mid-south disability
forum
and the disability forums is that is
that an appointment
of the councils though no it's not but
we have approached the council before
we're asking for a representation
and we've had various officers saying it
would be
raised yet we've heard nothing back so
if we could make a recommendation that's
the
disability forum has been requesting
not certain that falls within our remit
the remit of this committee is to
scrutinize the existing state
but we can certainly suggest that that
i don't know how to phrase this perhaps
it would be best to say
that we could examine
other potential outside bodies for the
future
um on the same basis as the ones we
already have
would that suffice i'd be happy with
that yeah my apologies thank you i don't
want i just don't want to make things
more complicated than they already are
this subject is a broad one and i don't
think it
we've already established it doesn't
receive much attention
over complicating the issue might be
sort of uh to putting too much on our
plate and on the plate
of our cabinets uh councillor robin
sorry jan robinson i think you have
something to say though jan yeah i just
wanted to clarify with the disability
forum we do have
officer representation on there so our
officers do do a lot of
work with the forum um obviously if
you still wanted to recommend looking at
whether you wanted to cancel appointment
but we do
have officer representation and we do
work quite closely with that forum
it's coming back to that question of the
uh
different approaches on citizen's advice
um
whereas officers have representation and
counsellors don't
um the question is whether councillors
wish to have representation
um i think it's a subject worthy of
discussion can we table
we mark a note on that henriette that
that's a potential
recommendation uh councillor ayers
thank you chair just like to um commend
janna actually because i live next door
to the new build of gainsborough's house
and so it's been quite um interesting to
say the least
but jan's actually been to all the
neighbors and kept a very close eye on
it as
our representative and thank you jan
because
she really has kept a tight hold on what
was happening with
you know all the um the heavy lorries we
had so many laura's lined up but
jan really um has been and negotiated
with the um the builders and it's been
brilliant so thank you
jen yes thank you very much for that
point council raz
uh jan robinson you're handlest and
raised is
something you wish to point out no fine
okay we'll move on that
brings us to the end of that list and
anybody else wish to add any further
groups
that uh they think should be brought to
the committee's attention
all right at this point then i think we
have this um
lengthy detailed table running from
pages
39 through to 45
looking at a variety of groups and i
believe this is the point where
jan you said that the some groups felt
that we no longer required
um representation i noticed the suffolk
joint emergency planning policy
panel has got crossing that crossings
out in it i wonder jan if i could ask
you to take us through
that list and highlight those groups
that believe that we
baber and mid suffolk councils uh
representation is no longer required
would that be helpful chair that yeah i
should i
would just run through i i'll try and
remember everything but if not i might
have to ask
henry i've got i've got the list in
front of me yeah so
on papers so i've got where it's in red
it we're being asked to say that we no
longer require representation and
actually baby domestic violence and
abuse forum
compassion as it's known as um they i
think their terms of reference have
changed and they no longer
need a counsellor representative
representative i think it's more like um
they have user groups with that now
which um they
find they use their expertise and don't
require a counsellor of representation
that was their response anyway so this
is the this is the list if i'm correct
then it's on the pages 31-37
yes no um well yeah
on it's it's called appointments of
representatives to outside bodies
and it's got um in red no
no longer yeah no longer let's look at
each of those in turn
yeah so the first one is the baby
domestic violence and abuse forum
compassion
yeah apparently councilor mclaren
representing on that
yeah and that's the one where we've
written to them and they've said that
actually they've had a change of
in their terms of reference and no
longer require cancer representation
it's more of a
inward group where they're actually
talking with people who represent
other groups from domestic violence and
so there's no longer a need for
councillors to to be on there
okay well council mclaren you're the
representative do you have any comment
upon that
uh yes chair in fact some of these small
the abuse groups i inherited from
another counsellor
so i've never had the opportunity to
attend any of their meetings
so it may be that it's actually
redundant in that sense absolutely
you wish um raise yes um
absolutely um i i would um agree with
what
um jan um robinson has just said
uh during my term as the representative
for sudbury domestic abuse they
beca suddenly became very very sort of
uh few and far between in meetings and
when i
um contacted them there was very little
information to hand um and i remember
attending one meeting um
and it was it was all to do with
these smaller groups um as jan is saying
so i would suggest that that is the
correct way to go
forward thank you so can we add that as
a potential recommendation that uh
from baber the uh domestic abuse forum
be removed
next one um again i'm going through
baber and then mid suffolk my apologies
if
that's the way they're the order they
come in uh the east west
rail consortium council halt isn't here
but i believe that this was dealing with
um
moving railway trains from the east to
the west and vice versa
yeah so the line through the line to
peterborough
yes it is and um they we have appointed
to it but
actually when we spoke to them they
require a subscription
for us to join and there was some
discussion around why we would want to
pay a subscription
if we didn't feel that we were getting
any value out of it so
um we although we're appointed we
haven't paid the subscription so that's
how it stands
really i think i think we're accepting
that when it comes to rail industry that
we are the last people to be considered
having been a rail user for many many
years including that peterborough line
i can i even commuted on it once uh i
can
testify that nobody cares what anybody
thinks
sorry that was a bit harsh but it's the
rail industry okay
uh for that one we can mark down as
something that we can recommend that uh
should be uh well removed from the list
yeah
the joint waste management board so
this one yes confused by so this is not
the same as
the um joint waste partnership boards uh
um it's a it's a duplication in fact so
um joint waste management would no
longer meet so
hence why um it's been superseded now so
um that can be removed yes okay another
recommendation then
suffer i mean we can do this all in one
uh
total recommendation henrietta that's
okay just a list of them for each
council
uh suffolk joint emergency planning
policy panel council
and councillor carpendale currently
representing yeah chair uh
again this is another panel that hasn't
met
so um hasn't met for a number of years
and
only really tends to to meet if there is
um something like a a massive
flood or you'd think a covert but a
19 pandemic but as it hasn't met in the
pandemic i'm not sure it's ever going to
meet so
um it's it's one that hasn't met for a
couple years so i think we can get
yeah so that add that to the list
suffolk rail policy group
i'm the representative on this one i was
appointed some
five and a half years ago it likewise
has never met and i
did query it for the first three years
um
and discovered i'm glad to say that the
only time that the suffolk rail policy
group would ever be expected to meet
would be in the event of a rail disaster
or um
accident so you don't want it to meet in
that
instance um so i don't know whether um
that
condition still applies but it's never
met in
five and a half years thank goodness
perhaps
yeah so chair that's another one that
hasn't met and um
is no longer going to meet i think it's
been superseded is that right henriette
yes yes uh jan and chair um i
um actually have a response from whoever
was organized and it said actually was
suffocation suspended a number of years
ago
so um amazingly enough never got around
to telling us
so i think we can safely take that off
the list
yes i think we pre safely can we now
come to the mid-suffolk um
matters um
uh the east-west rail consortium
councillor bruce to the representatives
there we have previously discussed that
um i don't know if you have anything to
add counselor brewster
no i'm there
um yes obviously the
um the the meetings of the consortium
are
always held in bedford or milton keynes
or something like that
the last one i attended there um
actually lasted just for an hour
um and it was really about the the
east-west rail on the
the other side of cambridge um
and and uh as i said it lasted for an
hour so there was a lot of driving to do
and which which was obviously put
expense on as well for
the council um more recently
there is an eastern uh uh
part of it which which obviously deals
with the rail
work going through mid suffolk so it is
some interest to us um having said that
um councillor smart at um ipswich
borough council
is um he really
leads these meetings there is a county
council it's an organized by county
council
um but yeah i mean i think
probably um we can rely on his
you know good will to keep it going at a
good level
it is an interesting one because uh
the one thing i was able to do when i
did attend the
second um bedford meeting
was that members there were saying on
that side of the country
were looking for passenger transport
not rail transport from
felixstowe or anywhere and i i was able
to swing that a bit so that they they
did accept that um
um that the um commercial uh
rail was was uh needed
and that's that does appear to be going
ahead but um
as i said the ipswich borough council
appear to be very
strong in it and i think they're
probably saying all that we could say
anyway
thank you very much councillor wellam
you have something to add to uh this
well yes it's just that you know we're
we we talk about climate change and we
want to get
more traffic on off the road and onto
the rail
and i feel we should be playing uh a
much bigger part in this
um and to rely upon um a counselor in
in ipswich who i i've never had any
feedback from him
um we we really ought to know what's
going
on um can i ask yeah i get your point
counselor
can i ask councillor brewster if the uh
east west rail consortium addresses
those points or is it actually a
different approach
um no they do address the points
from my experience anyway obviously
they're they're very keen to get
as much transport off the road um
onto rail um and
and uh it's certainly in their interest
to to
um you know to to get go that way
do we know if the subscription is a
substantial one
well this is it i don't know what the
prescription what the what the
subscription
is so you know okay
council uh henriette do you have a point
yes chair um following our briefing
i have actually tried to find out what
subscription fee is for this and we have
yet to receive response back from the
east west rail consortium but once i
have that i will let members know what
we what we would be charged
hm it may be we need to table this until
we have full information
council welum makes a point that you
know there is actually a requirement or
a desire
to get traffic off the roads although i
have to say
um the east west railway line
to peterborough doesn't strike me as the
sort of route that's going to take a
great deal of pressure off the road
simply because i've used it
i'm not sure it's capable of doing so
goods transport might be another matter
as councillor brewster referred to the
felixstowe connection
and of course it's our transport
corridor isn't it the a14 and the
railway line are more or less parallel
each other
yes so maybe that has to be put to one
side
we can return to that in discussion of
recommendations i think
the joint waste management board has
been already discussed
so we are coming to the close of this
document the joint emergency planning
policy panel has also been discussed
and moving down i believe that completes
the content of that document chair
yes completely
your icon isn't showing i didn't miss
that completely i apologize
okay that's all right and now it's just
a question on the east west rail
consortium
uh bearing in mind the changes to the
infrastructure on the stations along the
line
which passes through mid-suffolk um i'm
thinking of particularly needham market
stone market and thurston stations which
are all
about to receive uh improvements for
disability access
etcetera etc does that ever feed into
the east-west rail consortium
council of brewster i wonder whether you
might be able to advise on that
um improvements to those stations
no i've never never heard a conversation
about that at all
or even taking part in one obviously it
is important that we get those
improvements done
same as the hawley junction the hawley
junction certainly is spoken about
because that's quite um
paramount to what what's going on there
um
but i think the improvements to stations
is probably a
separate item uh which some of it is
obviously being
worked on at the moment okay
it occurs to me that the entire model
for uh
rail infrastructure in this country is
likely to change dramatically in the
next
few years as well i mean we're already
seeing that in
in changes made to the franchise system
and likely future changes so
there is a this is a lot of this is uh
up in the air
i have hands up from councillors
mayberry and eppinyon
councillor mayberry uh thank you very
much i was just uh
chair chairman i was just going to put
this in in the chat box
but talking um hearing the comments
about the uh the train stations
in certain areas in mid-suffolk reminds
me that
the access points along the sudbury
branch line
are also due to be renewed if
not if they haven't already been
completed so i think it is
important uh the sudbury branch line is
vitally important for sudbury
and that is a contributing factor
more north south councillor mayberry i
think though that's sort of
a branch off the main line from norwich
so
well um that's absolutely fine but if i
don't mention it
i'm aware the meeting has lasted nearly
two hours already and we have
we have covered a lot of subjects right
um
thank you uh council epping young did
you have something to say
uh thank you chairman yes i think um the
this
whole issue of the e-scale line um
perhaps is a little bit more important
because i think from
an lep point of view it's part of the
whole um
link between the east and the west in
terms of the technology
triangle within within our area
so i think we should pay some attention
in fact
because we are looking to be part of
that technology
um map going forward yep no i see your
point in fact
there there is actually a a section
there we've got gateway 14 we've got the
stone market and uh the corridor and the
a14 corridor
as i pointed out part of the railway
line
okay i think members we've we've covered
a great deal of ground
um i don't believe there are any other
groups that we are able to discuss at
this moment
but we do have some some draft
recommendations now to discuss
and i think that's the point at which we
should move um
the recommendations contained within the
paper um
are 3.1 that the joint overview and
scrutiny committee recommends to council
to remove the outside bodies no longer
requiring representation
based on information from the review as
detailed in appendix a and b
and i would suggest that what we do is
no longer requiring representation
being and then we'd put in a list of
those bodies that we can agree upon
so can i ask that as a proposal to start
with
um that that be discussed in
turn by turn if henriette could read us
through the ones that we have now
decided or we seem to believe should no
longer be
represented on henriette yes
yes chair um so we will be going as in
the
um appendix um a and b
so it will be the for paper it will be
the domestic violence and abuse
forum uh east west rail consortium the
joint waste management board and the
suffolk joint emergency planning
policy panel and the suffolk rail policy
group
and for uh mid-suffolk it will be the
well we well we have included the east
west rail consortium but i think we
should take that off
at the moment so it will be that appears
to be more
more important to to suffolk
than it does labor to my mind yes so
from itself it will not be the east-west
rail consortium so from itself
the the um the panels we are suggesting
to take off are the joint
waste management board the joint
suffix joint emergency planning policy
panel
and i think that's it for the rail
policy group
hang on the rail policy group
that's not even on this list well i
think it needs to be
okay they don't meet anyway so
pointless really i think uh perhaps the
case is that we didn't actually elect
any members for this one
let me just check for you chad i think
i'm still listed
are you i think so i'm not certain but
this was for me suffolk
chair the uh i've just done the
mid-south
divided up in baber and then mid suffolk
so it is as the two
appendices um are listed apart from its
suffolk where we will still include the
east
west rail consortium well i mean that
can
rather than included i think that might
be something that mid-suffolk members
wish to discuss further
yes i don't think we can make
recommendations for mid-suffolk
um and i think that's it appears likely
that from what
mid-suffolk councillors have said that
there is some debate about it and that's
really for the mid-suffolk members to
deal with isn't it
yes jeff i mean what do mid-suffolk
members think is that
is that more or less your view yes yeah
it should it shouldn't be on the list of
our bodies to
to which we won't send representatives
but we may have a
we may have a separate uh recommendation
which i guess would just be voted upon
by
mid-suffolk members of this time i
believe so
yes that would be dependent on what you
wish it to say
so the first recommendation 3.1 is that
those bodies
no longer require representation um we
remove the based on the information
from the review we just list those
bodies that they no longer require
it's our recommendation that these no
longer require uh
representation does that sound like a
suitable 3.1
members yes i'm i'm happy with that are
you looking for a seconder
i'm just sort of going through them i
mean i'm not going to vote on them yet i
just wanted to
establish what the first set of
recommendations should be
if anybody says no that's completely
wrong now say so
i'm happy with that chair that's fine
then
3.2 um i think we need to go back to the
individual
uh points we raised if henriette could
go through
the various matters that were raised as
we went through our discussion in turn
yes jim so the first recommendation you
were discussing was that the joint
overview and scrutiny committee
recommends presumably to council
that the haven gateway partnership
participation is considered in terms of
value and output
or you can um yes i believe that's the
case uh that
it should be considered in terms of
value output
um and relevance
okay would that be fair to make that 3.2
3.3 uh
that a member of uh the baba district
council be elected to home start
right well the baba district council
can consider representation on the home
start as
mid suffolk do okay that's
reasonable i think members any thoughts
please members at any point you have a
point to make just either raise your
hand or speak yes i would support that
chair
thank you that's what i'm looking for
some support so that would be that a
member of the baba district council
consider representation to be elected to
home start
well yeah that we should consider such
representation that's fine
in line in line with mid-suffolk i think
that's an important point the reasoning
behind it
uh then 3.4 so
uh so three point four this was for mid
suffolk members
that was the um that a mid-south uh
counselor be appointed or
be recommended to be appointed as an
observer to mid suffolk citizen advice
yes i believe that was what the wish of
the meeting was
uh councillor casten you had a point
um yes thank you yeah i i don't think
this is necessary to recommend this um
the um administration doesn't think that
we need
an observer on there and i agree with
them really the um we have
officers attending we have regular
officer meetings
and um i i just don't think it's
necessary i think the um the
administration have made a decision on
this and it's
and they have a perfect right to do what
we can do is make a recommendation they
can choose to act upon that
recommendation or not
um councillor scott so i don't i just
like to say i don't agree with this
recommendation
we will take each eye we each
recommendation in turn and we'll take a
vote on each one
so you have obviously able to vote for
or against in that or abstain on each
motion
each recommendation uh council as well
and scarf
do you have anything to say on that well
i feel very strongly that we should
appoint
which is why we'll have a vote yeah and
and likewise chair i mean
it's entirely up to each council
scrutiny committee
to determine what we wish to recommend
we are whether
or not it's entirely a personal decision
isn't it yeah
we are after all making recommendations
here and it is
going to be a matter for the cabinet or
the council to decide in each instance
so we're doing our job and that's all we
can do
so that was 3.4 for mid suffolk only
so we'll take each one in turn 3.5
henriette
um that that a reporting mechanism for
reps
representation or outside bodies be
established to provide valuable
information to members and the public
yes i think that's pretty much the will
of most members here
um i would also add 3.6 at this point
then
that uh i don't know what other members
experience has been but my own from the
very word go
has been that you get these appointments
and you're just thrown
into it without the clue of what you're
doing until you get the first set of
papers
i think i'd like to see more support
provided for members on outside bodies
as to what they are what they do not
just a broad outline of here it is a
piece of paper with some stuff on it
but actually some form of support in
terms of what members can expect
um what the responsibilities and yes
bringing in this reporting structure and
i think that goes hand in hand
with our reporting back for us to be
able to do that there must be support
given to members to do that any thoughts
on that counselors mclaren wellington
oh and counselor so jan robinson has
something to say as well
jan can you give us advice on that
so cancers i i agree and that is
something that we have
um i have certainly in my objectives to
actually get some more information about
outside bodies not
just for cancers but also for members of
the public who absolutely you know what
on earth are these bodies that people
we've been
so you know it's it's it's one of my
objectives to do that
i just wanted to check with councillors
that they're very clear on the roles
that they play when they're appointed to
these bodies not just
in from by the council but in their
private capacity as well because
it could be something that councils may
be interested in getting
further training on about the different
roles and
what those implications are for the
counsellor
um as i say in fact we can include
support
and training in the recommendation i
believe
yes now i have comments available from
councillors
mclaren and epping young i'll take them
in that order councilor mclaren
thank you chair yes um that was
something that was on my list
um of proposals
uh because uh all thanks to on
henriette for the spreadsheet
but the spreadsheet actually was a light
bulb moment for me
because it actually explained the whole
range of outside bodies and so that
reiterates the thought that
as new counselors or as counselors
taking over from somebody else
that there should be some follow-up and
education
uh educational sessions on a
regular basis thank you did you wish to
comment at that point
i do um that is why we are working as a
bigger piece of
information including the alphabetic
list of reps and outside bodies and we
are also going to
organize something on the public website
uh both for members and for the public
to see exactly
who is on the bodies and what they do
and how frequently
would that would that appear on the
scrutiny page henriette
uh we have yet to establish where it
should um appear as this would probably
be
for the whole of the council not just
exclusionary functions
uh counselor council and thank you
mccaskill mclaren
uh councillor wellam uh thank you
chairman yeah i
i agree training um some sort of
briefing
would be very much appreciated but just
to say that
um when i think i can speak to james as
well when we joined the
the drainage board we were told that
they would provide us with the training
they just haven't found an opportunity
in
what is it a year and a half um but um
the police and crime panel we do get a
briefing
from uh i mean it's run by the county
so we do get a briefing okay uh uh at
our first meeting each year i think it's
gonna be very variable but i think
principles should be established yeah
yes uh but i think
i think that uh our our officers could
probably get a lot of information
from the bodies to put towards a a
briefing package or training or whatever
for the members who are appointed and
previous members may be able to previous
representatives may be able to give
their input as well and if there was a
reporting structure
it would be easier for that to be
achieved
councillor eppinyon
thank you chairman i'm coming back to
recommendation
3.5 which is relates to the feedback uh
for from the representatives on outside
bodies
um it seems to me that we ought to sort
of quantify this a little bit
because there are many outside bodies
and many
meetings throughout the year and perhaps
we ought to have a quarterly
uh standing item on on the council
agenda to receive such feedback
i don't know what the mechanism would be
i think we're recommending that there be
a mechanism
and i got a feeling that we'll have to
discuss what the nature of that
mechanism should be
and i think that's going to be a matter
of discussion with officers
um and members um
and possibly the cabinet uh would you
like to comment henriette and janice
uh i don't know jen do you want to
comment first yeah so
so chair what we don't want to do is to
make this too onerous for councillors
you've got
such a lot of work to do um anyway
i think the easiest way to do it would
be to have a template
just with um date of the meeting some
details on and a short paragraph of what
what's covered and then we can actually
we could publish those as
either part of the council meeting or we
could take it as a regular update to
overview and scrutiny
i think that's an excellent suggestion i
don't know if it necessarily needs to go
through overview and scrutiny but it's
got to go
somewhere and we ought to take it to
council then but i wouldn't suggest that
we do it quarterly i think that would be
too onerous
i think i i think either six monthly or
or annually
a template strikes me as a good idea and
of course
we have a recommendation later on that
there be an annual review
um but we'll come to that later i think
that fits well into the recommendation
of an annual review
a template for reporting we have tried
to do this but we haven't received
very complete responses shall we say
from members
and i understand there's a lot of stuff
going on all the time
councillor eppinyong was that would that
answer your query
yes chairman i think jan's idea of
perhaps a twice a year um
templated report would be quite adequate
and
i mean the meetings happen at different
times so maybe
it could be as it happens well it's
still fresh in the mind to be honest
with you well indeed you know that won't
be a way of dealing with it
counselor um yeah thank you chair
i was just going to say we we really
don't want to have a
a formal report to to council because we
would find that we are reporting more
often than the cabinet members
yes and in some cases more lengthily
gasless scarf
thank you yeah i mean i think you're
right it can't be too onerous on the
members but it's not unreasonable
to actually expect at least once a year
some brief comment feedback from them
because
they gain the experience in their own
way and
and and and know the knowledge of these
bodies
but we don't as a council uh
then get that experience necessarily
relayed to us so i think
perhaps an annual just a short bullet
point description
of the work that the body's been doing
etcetera and if there is
an exceptional item one would expect
that the member who's on the outside
body would bring it back to the council
at the very first opportunity because it
might be a funding crisis
it could be a constitutional crime it
could be something where the council may
be able to offer assistance
if it's urgent there should be a
facility to do that anyway common sense
says so
um i like the idea of a template and i'd
just like to point out that we do
conduct an annual review at least one of
the recommendations will be that we
conduct an annual review as we are doing
here
and we did last year um so that's listed
as 3.2 on page 27
we'll obviously have a different
numbering now
so i think we've got the meat and bones
of that recommendation
if anybody doesn't want as any got no
further comments to make
uh henriette what was next okay so uh
sorry i was going to make another
comment but i can do that in a minute
and
so the final recommendation was um
that a consideration for
uh the council to appoint a
representation
uh on the disability forum as an
observer possibly
because i'm not sure they would have any
rights but maybe jan can help me with
that because we discussed
with councillor carter that he he
thought it was useful to have a
representation representation on the
disability forum
if they want us if they wanted you
i'm sorry but they mean blunt about it
um
okay so was that for both baber and
mid-suffolk
uh i think well they came from council
carter so i'm not sure whether that
would be for both
councils or not for the committee to
decide
it was for both councils all right
all right disability forum rather
mid-suffolk for is a suffolk disability
forum
which so both councils to inquire
whether representation would be
required or would be
greeted favorably i mean fundamentally
we are having to ask somebody else so
our recommendation is to ask somebody
else something
yes yeah well that's really
just a we have to say we recommend we
ask and we'll have
somebody will have to take it from there
does that answer your question
councillor carter
councillor wellam uh um uh sorry i was
about to move on to
an another rec was that the last
recommendation or
the last one we covered in our sort of
as we went through it
i've i thought that if if we're not
going to
um delete from the list the east-west
rail consortium that we ought to make a
recommendation that
council considered consider paying the
required
subscription so that we can attend
yeah i mean i think that was a
mid-suffolk one and i think
what was the recommendation as currently
written henriette
uh the recommendation is that we accept
um for mid suffolk um
appendix b um but that does not
include the east-west rail consortium
so the spell can state the east-west
rail consortium remains
on the list for representation i thought
we were just rather than saying you
referring to appendix as a an appendix b
we were actually going to list the
bodies we will list the bodies yes
but otherwise it gets too confusing
there's no point in having
recommendations
that require you to make a reference to
another document
um but if we don't make a recommendation
specifically in respect
of the east-west rail consortium it will
just remain on the list
but without a subscription being paid so
nobody attends
well i thought i got the impression that
the intent was that we
although the recommendation is not to do
it anymore that you'd like to explore it
further prior to actually having a
decision made
but that must be a matter for
mid-suffolk i don't think we're capable
of
making a recommendation with so many um
hypotheticals involved
so check we make a recommendation saying
that the mid-suffolk
over your exclusion committee explore
further
participation in the east west rail
consortium
would that be a recommendation you could
take forward
i would be happy to take that forward
would you save the cabinet of
mid suffolk rather than overview and
scrutiny we are the overview and
scrutiny here
we're already exploring it but i mean it
requires somebody in authority if you
like to take
to take a decision check can i just come
in as i said before this is a council
decision so
all you can ever do is recommend that to
to council that they explore it further
and and with the view to
either paying the subscription or or not
to be a member of it anymore but that
that needs to be a recommendation to
council
yeah right so recommendation to council
we can't recommend to ourselves
okay
okay my apologies i was the one person
who should have turned my phone off and
didn't
right okay so let's go through the
recommendations in turn
just one moment chair and then we will
get proposers seconders and vote on each
recommendation
in terms of again so let's see if i can
find we have quite we have eight so the
first one is
three point one that the over joint
overview and security committee
recommends to council that
to remove the outside bodies no longer
required representation based on the
information
from the view as detailed in appendix a
and appendix b but we will change that
to
a based uh uh uh
no longer require representation um as
listed
yeah the lists for both baber and
mid-suffolk and then listed below
the separate lists all right so three
points
three point that so that's three point
one a three point three point two
let's deal 3.1 first
let's take a proposer and a second uh i
propose thank you
uh councillor osborne proposing second
up happy to second
thank you that's the well and seconding
then we need to take
a vote on that uh by roll call
yes chair so uh councillor carter
councillor brandon four
councillor mccraw four castle mclaren
four councillor muller four councillor
osborne
four castle scarf paul
how's the willam that's unanimous chair
thank you and then 3.2
3.2 is that the joint overview and
security committee recommends to council
that the haven gateway partnership
participation is considered in terms of
value
and output sorry value output and
relevance
sorry can you repeat that
that the joint overview and scrutiny
committee recommends to council that the
haven gateway partnership
participation is considered in terms of
value
output and relevance
is that strong enough what do members
think
uh chair yes catherine
chairman i i'm not sure that's a
terribly meaningful recommendation
um i i thought that the the thrust of it
was that
we were doubtful that our continued
membership represented good value
etc okay let's let's find a wording that
states that that we
the the overview and scrutiny committee
um
cannot see that those points have been
represented and that we should both
councils should consider withdrawal from
the haven gateway partnership
does that cover it
more or less from my perspective
chairman that's my feeling
view as well can we reword that
henrietta
okay it does not that we cannot
we haven't it's not been demonstrated
that the haven gateway partnership
um demonstrates those points
value etc and
both councils should consider withdrawal
it's a recommendation
councillor osborne you had a point to
make
yeah thank you thank you mr chairman um
one thing
uh having come from that direction in my
early life
you'll find that um most of that haven
gateway
was associated with tendon juristic
council and harrage and et cetera
so where we stand on this i have no idea
but
all i can say perhaps is that this is uh
an area that is taken away from anyone
any one of us either mid-south
well not so much mid-summit but
definitely baba um
to the point that it's attending just
your council concern and most of the
funding
uh i believe comes from uh goes to
tendering district council
i think it's harrich and felix stow
effectively
and none of us none of us are involved
in harris or felix stowe directly
just peripherally
so sorry chair can you just got a word
have you got a wording henry yet sorry
no not really not for the last part
because i have the joint overview
security committee
recommends that the council consider
withdrawal from the gateway haven
partnership as the committee
what exactly is it committee cut feels
it cannot demonstrate
it does does not demonstrate uh what
were the points we once said originally
relevance was one value value and
relevance
value relevance and well it was output
but that's
maybe not the correct word value
your hand is raised and counselor maybe
your hand is raised
thank you uh um cameron um
i'm sorry i didn't come on comment on
this earlier i'm having quite a lot of
trouble with my technology here
um but i seem to recall that when john
hinton councillor john hinton
um was on this board
he was very involved and found it very
useful
and i seem to recall that it had some
implications for the a12 and so on as
well
and had some implications on
his ward i believe councilor granted he
wanted it to have some relevance to the
a12
but i don't believe that it ever did
ah okay i mean we're making the
recommendation it's not being devastated
if if it's going to be demonstrated let
somebody demonstrate it is what i think
we're trying to suggest here
again we're only making a recommendation
not a decision
okay i'm happy with that then
that's my point i mean you know i was
just that we are not
making a decision here we're making a
recommendation
that was the mood i got from the
discussion in the meeting councillor
scarf oh sorry councillor mayberry did
you have anything to add to this
thank you mr chairman i am i'm not on
the committee may i comment or not well
just briefly yes please right thank you
uh
my suggestion would be that um
you asked the respective uh chief
executive
officers for the two areas as to whether
you
they think that it is of use well in
effect our recommendation to cabinet
we'll bring that about anyway
this this is a means of asking uh
without actually asking
counselor scarf uh thank you chair well
i'm just going to make the point
um on the mid-suffolk list it it lists
councillor brewster
uh who we've heard talk today uh the
evidence of the haven gateway
partnership
as the baby district council substitute
now
well it's he's listed as the baby
district council substitute because
there's one plus one substitute
now if we're two sovereign bodies
one would have thought that we would
each have a representative i mean i'm
i'm not
not necessarily in favor of the haven
gateway partnership membership but that
does
create an area of confusion because you
can't have a substitute
for one it's a misprint i believe
council
may i clarify sorry that it's obviously
a mistake on
um administration apartments so
council brewster is the representative
for mid-suffolk and here in gateway
partnership
i'm councillor holt for baber that's
great
so on that proviso we're making a
recommendation
that this be re-examined um
by whoever cabinet i would guess council
i would guess
um that would bring about the sort of
responses from the chief executives that
one would expect
but i think we have enough evidence
considering at least one of the
representatives
doesn't think it's worth the time and it
may not be for mid-suffolk
but it may be for baber but that's yet
to be demonstrated
we can make the recommendations so do we
have a proposal for that
we're happy to propose mr chairman
and second happy to second chairman
councillor epping yong thank you very
much
can we take a role can i just ask was it
counselor
who who it was counselor and a proposer
counselor osborne osborne sorry no
problem
right i will be doing a roll call again
council grandin four
councillor mccraw four
council mclaren four counselor muller
four councillor osborne four councillor
scarf
or councilwell that's unanimous chair
thank you very much members move on to
the third recommendation henriette
that a member of the
baba district council consider
representation to be elected to the home
start uh so that was actually both
council sorry that a member of
hang on let me just the representatives
for both councils
should be considered for considered
and dis and discussions open with home
start
that's correct that representation from
both councils
uh be considered for to be elected to
the home start in line will miss
southwark actually i'm sorry chad
i got this wrong that a member of the
baba district council
uh be considered to be elected to home
start in line with
um mid-suffolk district council that's
fine
who was the proposal for that we haven't
got one yet chair
i will propose that counselor mclaren
proposing yes church a second
please i think this will be for baber
our secretary
that's councillor gould thank you very
much so that can we take a roll call
vote on that third recommendation
so you would only want the baba members
to vote labour members yes
right so counselor gold
council grandin four
councillor mccraw four council mclaren
for council osborne four
and i believe that's all is that correct
that's all chair that's unanimous
thank you very much uh the fourth
recommendation
right chair the fourth recommendation is
that
uh
okay that um consideration
that that baba district council uh
consider representation uh to be
appointed as an observer to miss suffolk
citizen advice does that make sense no
sorry i meant that yeah
i lost that one do you apologize
for mid-suffolk members only i believe
the effects
so in line with in line with baber's
representation or of on observer status
for citizens advice that mid suffolk
uh reconsider their
representation okay
and that this will be for the
mid-suffolk members only to vote upon so
we'll need proposers and seconders for
that does that
meet your wishes mid-suffolk members yes
yes it does i'm happy to propose
okay we have councillor whelan proposing
and reconsidered
and councillor scarf seconding okay
so we'll carry out a roll call vote on
that
yes certainly chairman
four uh
[Music]
council muller four council scarf
oh how's the willing
so chair that is uh five votes four and
one against
okay so that's carried that will go
forward as a recommendation
the fifth recommendation
lost the fifth recommendation one moment
um
so that was that um that a reporting
mechanism for representation outside
bodies be
established to provide valuable
informations to members and the public
okay and we could perhaps mention
potentially with a template
to feed in to the
annual review by overview and scrutiny
of the template
um a basic structure
and we're also proposing a place where
the report goes
and i think that would be sufficient
to be presented to the joint ons
annual review annual review yeah
yes chair so would you like me to read
that again yes if you could
okay that report you may comment
recognize excuse me sir chair
that reporting mechanism in the form of
a template
for representation outside bodies be
established to provide valuable
information to members
and the public to present it to the
joint overview and scrutiny annual
review
yep we'll have to come back to that
joint annual review in a separate
recommendation and then
insert it in front of this one but we'll
do that that's the one originally listed
at 3.2
so do i have a proposal for that
mechanism chairman i'm happy to propose
uh councillor eppinyong seconder
well i'm happy to second that oh
councillor caston i'll take your
recommend your second on that
uh so that's epping young and cast on
proposing seconding
can we take a roll call vote for both
councils councillor carter
four councillor casten paul
councillor four
osborne port how's the scarf
oh councilwellum poor that's unanimous
chair
thank you very much uh the next
recommendation would this be the sixth
it's correct yeah let me find it so
the next one is that support and
training be established for members when
appointed as
a representative on outside bodies
yep that covers it i'm happy to propose
that
counselor um carter seconding
yep got councillor carter secondly i
think yes chair
okay let's take a roll call for both
councils please
counselor carter
council mclaren ball council muller
or house osborn four
how's the scarf oh how's the willam
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much now that was all the ones we've
discussed so far we now return to 3.2
on the papers which establishes the
principle of an annual review once again
could you reread that uh from the papers
please henriette
yes jer let me just find it on my paper
so
that a review of the list of outside
bodies be conducted on an annual basis
and that the upgrade of that review be
included in an
annual report presented to this
committee
i think that's perfectly adequate um i
don't think it will be as exhaustive as
this
year's has been i've imagined much like
some of the other jobs we do
that every second year will be more in
depth but
we keep it going on an annual basis so
uh can i have a proposal for that
recommendation
which i believe we should probably list
as five
and move the other two down one because
then it would come in just before
the annual review referred to in the
next recommendation
a chair um yeah
you would like this 3.2 to be
recommendation five
yes i believe so and then that would
make the other that would make five six
and six
seven and it would actually read
logically
in the order of the recommendations okay
that's just a matter of presentation
okay i think i see councillor carter are
you proposing councillor carter yes
maybe surprise
and the second to please counselor
epigong
okay so uh can we take a roll call vote
for both councils please
certainly so that will be three but just
one moment so okay i'm just gonna get
this
sorted my notes
okay so counselor carter four councillor
castin
paul councillor epc four house of gold
four casa granden
four that's unanimous chair
thank you very much henriette thank you
very much members
witnesses all and officers because we've
given a pretty decent coverage on that
yeah um yes
councillor sorry henriette i believe we
have a further
recommendation i missed one did i what's
that and that was that the
mid suffered district council explored
further represent participation or
representation
in relations to the east west rail
consortium
right correct my apologies so this would
be a matter for the uh
mid-suffolk members councillor welling
are you proposing
yeah happy to propose and a seconder
from mid-suffolk council even
this is east-west rail consortium which
is of relevance to mid-suffolk more than
labour
can we take a roll-call vote please
henriette certainly councillor carter
or cassella casten
thank you very much my apologies members
for missing one so we've now got
a total of eight recommendations that's
correct jen
okay i'm glad i can still count thanks
very much members as i say we've covered
an
area that i don't think has had much
light thrown on it i hope we've done so
we'll now move i think to the next item
on the agenda
i'm sure you're only too pleased to hear
that
and this is item nine the forthcoming
decisions list
all members have had a chance i hope to
have a look at that um are there any
comments
on that
not then uh for noting anyway and it is
something in constant review
uh by the chairs at their meetings each
month
uh so we move on sorry i'm having
trouble with my documents at the moment
two items 10 and 11 which are
respectively the baber and mid suffolk
overview and scrutiny
work plans and these are presented on
from table
page 47 of the reports um
you can see that we have a schedule
pretty much taking us
up to april which for the moment we have
kept
open um because there's a possibility of
the
county council elections there's
possibility of some form of purdue
um but there's plenty of time if we need
to fill that in
um any comments on those raise you use
the raise hand function
nope up councillor welum
councillor welling
your hand is ready yeah yeah i don't
know if i can propose that we accept
both of them since one is from
mid-suffolk one is for baber but
certainly i i feel that uh that's fine
both of them are fine
i'm not i'm sure there's a necessity for
there only for noting
there's no need for item 12 because we
have already dealt with the
uh confidential minutes so uh we shall
pass that
and the same goes for item 13.
um fundamentally
members this concludes the meeting um
i believe i'm right sorry henriette
chair i'm not sure where the council is
would like to
mention anything about the gypsy and um
i apologize i was something that was
going to be brought up we will just
briefly go back into this as a subject
we didn't discuss
uh the options there available there is
a group uh that
councilors would like to discuss um i'm
not sure
this is an appointment or an internal um
external organization
but it's of some interest counselor airs
thank you chair
um it's just that um we do meet sort of
every other month we have a meeting
next monday but i do feel all the
counsellors should be aware of the
problems that they're having
they're not always given the respect or
whatever i know there are problems
obviously i know about that and they're
all treated as a nuisance
but there are five different groups of
travelers for example
um they have a big burial site at long
melford
which has been um with this particular
family for 300 years
and i think um we really need and we are
fighting to get
some sort of traveler transit site
because we don't have transit sites
that's when they park up in places where
they shouldn't be so
um i would like to give a report at some
stage um
of the progress that we're we're trying
to make but
it's a very important committee and i do
value jane
being on that committee with me thank
you
thank you very much councillors uh
well i think we've given the counselor
google do you wish to say something
what just a second rock councillors has
said really
um that i feel it is a committee that
does move things along
and it does scrutinize in some detail
what's happening and
i'd like to think that um the members on
the committee
um do offer some fresh ideas and and
support to the
um the paid officers who who are dealing
with this particular
group of society people
yeah to secretary councillors as i
recall
baber has no uh sites gypsy or traveller
sites whereas mid suffolk does
is that correct yes it is correct
at the moment um and the other problem
is and
essex in fact don't have any and i've
been told by
county council if we have them they'll
send them all up from essex so
there's a lot of discrimination there
i'm afraid okay
tough subject uh right
members thank you for all for your
considerations today as i say we've
covered a subject that doesn't normally
get aired i think we've covered it in
some depths although we could obviously
speak more
but that concludes this meeting the next
joint overview and scrutiny committee
meeting will be on monday the 14th of
december
2020 9 15 a.m
for a set up and starting at 9 30
p.m i'll now declare the meeting closed
thank you
you